[Música]
y vamos ya con la economía aquí en
directo a América edición nocturna hoy
nos acompaña nuestro compañero Juan
Pablo lucumí Juan Pablo bienvenido
Buenas noches una vez más acá una vez
más y no será la última seguro vamos a
empezar hablando de Twitter que ha
empezado a repartir parte de sus
ingresos entre los usuarios cuéntame
cómo funciona esto porque yo uso
bastante Twitter a ver si algo me llega
bueno para usted y para las personas que
nos ven también los creadores de
contenido el dinero empezó a entregarse
solo para esas personas aquellos que se
consideran creadores de contenido cuando
los comentarios de sus tweets salga
publicidad de algunas marcas un
escenario similar a YouTube pocas redes
sociales tienen esta monetización pues
YouTube es una de ellas y ahora Twitter
para poder acceder a estos pagos los
usuarios deben estar suscritos a Twitter
Blue que es la membresía mensual de pago
también deben tener una cuenta de stripe
para aunar esas comisiones y tener más
de 5 millones de impresiones de sus
tweets de forma mensual Durante los
últimos meses para que vaya anotando sin
embargo desde el año pasado tuviera
perdido muchos ingresos publicitarios
por las constantes polémicas alrededor
del Magnate elon musk las ventas de
publicidad de la plataforma en Estados
Unidos registraron 88 millones de
dólares en abril de este año una
disminución cercana al 60% si se compara
con el período de abril de 2022 Y aunque
la red social ya empezó a pagarle a los
creadores de contenido todavía no ha
publicado Como calcula el porcentaje que
paga a cada creador me imagino que
precisamente debido a esas pérdidas es
que están buscando nueva forma de hacer
negocio en Twitter evidentemente y deben
garantizarle a los creadores de
contenido este dinero porque si no está
redes sociales se acaban básicamente
Bueno vamos a cambiar de tema porque hoy
a la medianoche hora de no sé Estados
Unidos no sé ahora me contarás
exactamente de qué parte de Estados
Unidos empieza la huelga de actores de
Hollywood como ha afectado esto a las
ganancias las compañías de
entretenimiento en esta jornada de hoy
pues es hora local hora precisamente de
Hollywood California el escenario fue
paradójico al cierre de las operaciones
en bolsa porque se esperaría que sólo
con el anuncio de la huelga y el
escenario de incertidumbre que se viene
esto haga presión en los inversionistas
y a su vez se vea reflejado en los
números rojos de las compañías que
cotizan en bolsa como ya sabemos Rodrigo
cualquier rumor puede afectar estas
acciones sin embargo el resultado de hoy
fue un poco contradictorio con muchas de
esas empresas con significativas
ganancias al cierre de Wall Street y lo
verán ahora en sus pantallas Netflix una
de las principales empresas de servicio
de streaming cerró este jueves con un
significativo
1,43% y lo vamos a ver acá otra de los
cuales Tuvo una leve ganancia fue Walt
Disney con el 0,35% esta compañía de la
empresa Disney Plus o la plataforma de
streaming Paramount con un 1,69% pero la
que más sorprendió fue Amazon con un
increíble 2,68% y decimos increíble
porque en este escenario Pues que tengan
ganancias es bastante de paradójico
desde luego Juan Pablo ahora vamos a
hacer un repaso a las peticiones que
están haciendo los actores en huelga
vamos a recordar estas peticiones porque
ese pues supone el primer paro laboral
Dual que debe enfrentar Hollywood en 63
años porque ahora no solo son los 11.500
guionistas que llevaban En paro desde el
2 de mayo sino que también se les unen
los 160.000 actores del sindicato más
grande de Hollywood veamos ahora las
peticiones una de ellas es que tanto su
salarios como el pago de derechos
residuales sea más justo esos derechos
residuales se refieren al porcentaje que
reciben cuando las producciones en las
que trabajan son vendidas por ejemplo a
cadenas de televisión y siguen
constantemente pues recibiendo estas
ganancias también piden garantía para
que su trabajo no sea reemplazado por
Inteligencia artificial un escenario que
también pues se ha hablado que
presentadores actores van a poder ser
reemplazados y que tengan una
compensación adecuada si esto llega
muy bien Juan Pablo pues Seguiremos
atentos a cómo sigue esa huelga por el
momento nos vamos a Argentina porque
allí la inflación no da tregua y sigue
el alza lo hemos revisado mes a mes
porque pues los datos anuales se ven que
hay un incremento en la tasa de
inflación de ese país en donde ya se va
a cumplir un año exacto de este camino
al alza desde el 71% anual de julio de
2022 hoy se conoció el dato de junio de
este año y la tasa interanual se ubicó
en el
115,6% desde el 114,2% anual que reportó
el mes inmediatamente anterior y aunque
con el dato de junio se puede ver que el
incremento mensual es mucho menor a los
altos que se daban un año hace un año
cuando saltaba el 71 al 78% anual entre
julio y agosto Sin embargo a este pues
escenario el alza de precios sigue
complicando las compras diarias de los
ciudadanos escuchemos
en realidad lo que veo y noto es que hay
mucha diferencia entre precios y calidad
o sea te quieren vender un kilo de
tomate a cada 200 ejemplos en la esquina
500 pesos siento que no hay un control
que nadie controla los precios y que
cada uno con el precio que quiere y
quizás manejando la misma calidad Sí
bueno el cliente se está cuidando un
poquito más en lo que gasta y
está llevando Generalmente los cortes
más económicos lo que es carne molida o
corte para hacer filetes o carne para
estofado pues Juan Pablo esto ha sido
todo por hoy mañana más todo por hoy en
economía mañana con mucho más